[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin guten Abend Wintersport und
Fußball später bei dir Christin und auch
Jubel beim Tennis guten Abend unsere
Themen jetzt an diesem
Samstag Signal gegen Rechtsextremismus
Deutschland weit gibt es wieder
Demonstrationen allein in Berlin
protestieren
150.000 Menschen
Vergeltungsschläge nach Drohnenangriffen
das us-mitär attackiert Stellungen
pro-iranischer Milizen im Irak und in
Syrien und Erfolg im monobob Lisa
buckwitz holt den emtitel und verteidigt
damit ihre Führung im
Gesamtweltcup es ist das inzwischen
dritte protestwochenende in Deutschland
gegen Rechtsextremismus und für
Demokratie in fast allen Bundesländern
gibt es kundgeben mehr als 60 allein
heute die größte Versammlung gab es in
Berlin zu der ein breites Bündnis von
mehr als 1800 Verbänden und Initiativen
aufgerufen hatte die Polizei spricht von
über 150 000 Teilnehmern Stefan
Merseburger
[Musik]
berichtet die Menschen sind in Scharen
vor den Bundestag gekommen trotz
Nieselregen und starken Windböhen wir
sind die Brandmauer lautete der Aufruf
der veranstal
sieollten ein Zeichen setzen gegen
Rechtsextremismus und Hass für Toleranz
und
Demokratie ja weil ich unsere Freiheit
schützen muss und weil ich natürlich
dafür kämpfen muss dass wir so weiter
leben können wie wir gerade Leben 30
Jahre lang hier in Deutschland haben wir
in Demokratie gelebt und wir lieben das
und wir
möchten wir müssen raus auf die Straße
und unsere Stimme erheben damit die
recht nicht immer nur gehört werden und
alle Aufmerksamkeit bekommen wir sind
mehr weil vor allen Dingen die Menschen
die als Protest weder die AFD
wählen jetzt merken dass das kein
Prozess ist sonder Protest ist sondern
einfach der falsche Weg seit Wochen
ebben die Demonstrationen gegen die
Rechtsextremen und den scheinbar
unaufhaltsamen Aufstieg der AFD nicht ab
jetzt zeigen Umfragen dass die AFD an
Zuspruch verliert eine Folge der
Proteste muss man sehen das ist auch
eine Polarisierung die da stattfindet
das verfestigt sicherlich auch den
festen Kern der AFD aber gerade so diese
schwankenden zweifelen Wählerinnen und
Wähler die kommen sicher jetzt noch mehr
ins Grübeln ob sie wirklich bei der AFD
zu Hause sind Gewerkschaften Kirchen und
Gruppierungen mehr als 1800
Organisationen stehen hinter dem Bündnis
Hand in
Hand wir haben diese Freiheit geschenkt
bekommen aber sie ist nicht
selbstverständlich lasst uns sie nutzen
und lasst uns beweisen was für ein
geiles Land wir sind
danke eine Menschenkette um den
Bundestag Bilder mit Symbolkraft Bürger
schützen das Hohe Haus der
Demokratie auch in vielen anderen
deutschen Städten wurde gegen
Rechtsextremismus demonstriert in
Dresden gingen nach Schätzungen des
Veranstalters rund 30.000 Menschen für
Solidarität und gegen Hass und Hetze auf
die Straße die zweite große Demo binnen
zwei Wochen 300 Organisationen hatten in
Freiburg zum Marsch aufgerufen nach
Polizeiangaben zogen hier rund 30.000
Demonstranten durch die
Innenstadt afdchef krupalla sieht in den
landesweiten Protesten ein
Ablenkungsmanöver der Regierung und rief
im Deutschlandfunk interterview Bürger
dazu auf sich Zitat nicht von
staatlichen Institutionen missbrauchen
zu lassen gleichzeitig appellierte er an
Parteimitglieder sich zu mäßigen erst
vor kurzem rief ein ZDF Bericht über den
brandenburgischen AFD Abgeordneten
hühnig den Verfassungsschutz auf den
Plan dessen Äußerungen zu stat und
Demokratie schlagen weiterhin hohe
Wellen mehr von Nicola Albrecht
Falkensee in Brandenburg am 18 Januar
der AFD Ortsverband hat zum Bürgerdialog
eingeladen Gastredner der
Landtagsabgeordnete Lars hünich der
schimpft über angeblich korrupte
Politiker und Parteien und verspricht
seinen Zuhörern schließlich wenn wir
morgen Regierungsverantwortung sind dann
müssen wir diesen Parteienstaat
abschaffen den Parteienstaat abschaffen
diese Aussage sorgt für Empörung und
Diskussion im Innenausschuss des
Brandenburger Landtags
verfassungsschutzchef Müller zeigt sich
alarmiert er hat einen direkten Angriff
auf die parlamentarische Demokratie
gestartet indem er sagt wir schaffen
diesen Parteienstaat ab und verstößt
damit gegen Artikel 21 Grundgesetz das
Parteienprivileg dort steht eben drin
dass die Parteien am politischen
Meinungsbildungsprozess des Volkes
mitwirken und dagegen verstößt er die
AFD sieht sich unterdessen als Opfer
einer Hetzkampagne sie würde böswillig
missverstanden der brandenburgische
Innenminister stübgen entgegen sieht gar
Parallelen zur NS Diktatur Zitat mit dem
Kampfbegriff Parteienstaat wurde schon
einmal die parlamentarische Demokratie
abgeschafft das war
1933 und Politikwissenschaftler sind
sich einig die vielfältige parteienland
ist Grundpfeiler der pluralistischen
Demokratie es ist sicherlich nicht so
dass man nicht Kritik an Parteien üben
darf oder an bestimmten Entscheidungen
die gefällt werden es ist etwas
qualitativ völlig anderes die
Abschaffung des parteienstaats mit dem
Wort Parteienstaat insbesondere zu
fordern für die AFD in Brandenburg
könnte dieser Fall Folgen haben der
Verfassungsschutz will ihn in die
Bewertung ob die Partei als gesichert
rechtsextremistisch eingestu werden soll
mit einfließen
lassen die Bauern protestieren weiter
gegen den Wegfall der Steuerentlastungen
beim Agrardiesel heute rund um den
Frankfurter Flughafen laut Polizei kamen
Landwirte mit rund 400 Traktoren
zusammen die Flughafengesellschaft hatte
Passagiere dazu aufgerufen mehr Zeit bei
der Anreise einzuplanen die Zugänge zu
den Terminals sein aber nicht blockiert
gewesen wenn sie einem Amerikaner
Schaden zu fügen werden wir antworten so
hatte es US-Präsident beiden angekündigt
nach dem Tod von drei Soldaten bei einer
drohenattacke in Jordanien jetzt folgte
die Antwort des us-mitärs aus der Luft
Griff es nach eigenen Angaben mehr als
85 Ziele im Irak und in Syrien an wie
etwa Kommandozentralen und Waffenlager
die Angriffe hätten den iranischen
Revolutionsgarden und mit Teran
Verbündeten Milizen gegolten dies sei
erst der Anfang erklärte beiden aber ein
einen Krieg wolle er nicht
elmaesen das Ziel lag mitten in einer
Wohnstraße aber die Anwohner in Keim im
Irak bestätigen dass hier das Waffen und
Raketenlager einer Miliz getroffen wurde
ein zivilistst ihr Ärger richtet sich
gegen die irakische Regierung sie solle
dafür sorgen dass das Militär aus ihren
Wohnvierteln
verschwinde amerikanische B1 Bomber
waren in Texas gestartet ein Signal dass
die USA jeden beliebigen in der Welt
treffen könnten auch in Iran die Ziele
jetzt lagen in Irak und Syrien auch
Stützpunkte der kzforce der Eliteeinheit
der iranischen
revolutionsgab Irans Innenminister
verurteilt die Angriffe sie würden die
Flammen des Widerstandes anfachen man
müsse Weise handeln anders als die
Amerikaner es ist Vergeltung für die bei
einem drohenangriff getöteten
US-Soldaten aber auch Abschreckung gegen
Iran und seine Helfer eine Gradwanderung
für den Präsidenten die USA so ließ er
wissen wollten keinen Krieg aber wer
ihnen schade bekomme eine Antwort und
das sei nur der
Auftakt es ist wichtig zu verstehen dass
es nur Teil einer Kampagne ist nicht ein
einmaliger präzisionsschlag auf ein
spezielles
Ziel Biden hat bereits weitere
Luftschläge befohlen und im Pentagon
liegen Pläne für direkte Angriffe auf
den Iran bereit wenn die Attacken auf
US-Truppen weitergehen letzte Nacht
mussten uskampfjets wieder
Drohnenangriffe von der Iran nahen huti
Miliz
abwehren fragen wir noch mal in
Washington nach Elma es ist eine äußerst
angespannte Situation in Nahost vor
diesem Hintergrund wie viel Risiko
steckt in den
us-angriffen ja das Risiko einer
eskalationsspale ist wirklich real ein
Beispiel wenn eine Miliz die zwar mit
dem Iran verbunden aber vielleicht nicht
aus Terran gesteuert wird wenn diese
Miliz eine einen großen Anschlag verübt
bei dem viele US-Soldaten sterben dann
könnte das ganz leicht weiter eskalieren
und die US-Regierung will drei Dinge tun
um das zu verhindern das eine sind eben
diese Luftschläge es geht darum die
Fähigkeiten der Milizen und auch der
iranischen Revolutionsgarden so zu
verringern überhaupt Schaden zuzufügen
und das zweite ist dass sie US-Regierung
diese Angriffe mit Ansage macht das
heißt man gibt das vorher bekannt es
gibt den Milizen und anderen Gelegenheit
sich in Sicherheit zu bringen aber ihr
Material ihre Waffen ihre Fähigkeiten
sollen zerstört werden und das dritte
ist dass auf einem backchannel das heißt
also über Umwege man auch in
Kommunikation steht mit Terran selber
man will dem Regime dort sehr sehr klar
machen es muss seine Macht nutzen und
die hat es ja in der Region diese Macht
nutzen um den Milizen klar zumachen
jetzt ist Schluss keine weiteren
Angriffe also mit diesen Maßnahmen will
man versuchen die Eskalation zu
verhindern danke für die Analyse nach
Washington Elm
twisen für Nordirland ist es heute ein
historischer Tag denn zum ersten Mal hat
die britische Provinz eine
Regierungschefin die sich für eine
Vereinigung mit der Republik Irland
einsetzt Michelle O'Neil von der
katholischen shinfin Partei
zusammenarbeiten muss sie allerdings mit
der protestantischen DUP die will eine
enge Anbindung an Großbritannien dass
beide Seiten an einer Regierung
beteiligt sein müssen das schreibt das
freitagsabkommen vor das
1998 den jahrzehntelangen blutigen
Bürgerkrieg beendet hatte wie beide
Parteien knapp zwei Jahre nach der Wahl
jetzt doch noch zusammengekommen sind
berichtet Jassin
herlein der Begriff historisch ist in
Nordirland ja schon häufiger verwendet
worden die Geschichte der Aussöhnung
nach 30 Jahren Bürgerkrieg hat immer
neue Meilensteine hervorgebracht heute
war es die Ernennung der ersten
katholischen republikanischen ersten
Ministerin
dass ein solcher Tag kommen würde wäre
für die Generation meiner Eltern und
Großeltern undenkbar gewesen doch dank
des K freitagsabkommens ist dies
Vergangenheit und wir haben eine
demokratischere und gerechtere
Gesellschaft dies ist jetzt ein besserer
Ort für uns
alle vor zi Jahren wurde o'ils Partei
shinfein die langfristig eine
Wiedervereinigung mit der Republik
Irland anstrebt stärkste Kraft in BEL
die Großbritannien treuen
protestantischen Unionisten verweigerten
sich jedoch einer gemeinsamen Regierung
beizutreten denn sie befürchteten dass
Nordirland von Großbritannien
abgeschnitten werde aufgrund von
Zollkontrollen im wahrenverkehr zwischen
der Provinz und dem Rest des Königreichs
im Zuge des brexitabkommens diese
Probleme sind nun ausgeräumt und die
Unionisten stellen die stellvertretende
erste Ministerin es wurde aber auch
langsam Zeit finden die meisten in
Bast vielleicht wird jetzt wier Geld
investiert wo es gebraucht wird ins
Gesundheitswesen in Schulen Jobs es ist
eine harte Zeit
gewesen ich hoffe einfach dass die Dinge
nun besser werden wir müssen
hoffnungsvoll
bleiben es muss eine Menge gemeinsame
Regierungsarbeit nachgeholt werden nur
das sichert dauerhaft eine friedliche
Zukunft in Nordirland darin sind sich
alle
einig wer in Russland gegen Präsident
Putins Angriffskrieg auf die protestiert
der muss mit Strafen rechnen in Moskau
sind heute trotzdem Angehörige von
Soldaten auf die Straße gegangen dazu
aufgerufen hatten Frauen deren Ehemänner
im Zuge der Mobilmachung in die Ukraine
geschickt worden waren am Grab des
unbekannten Soldaten an der kremmelmauer
legten sie Blumen nieder die Polizei
nahm 27 Menschen fest unter ihnen auch
ausländische
Journalisten die Solidarität mit den
Soldaten ist groß in der Ukraine auch
wern nicht an der frontkämpf der will
helfen im ganzen Land sammeln die
Menschen Geld warme Kleidung Erste Hilfe
Utensilien oder selbstgebackenes unsere
reporterin Anne Brühl hat eine der
zahlreichen Initiativen
besucht unterstützt die die uns
verteidigen steht an der Häuserecke im
Zentrum von Kiev es ist das Motto dieses
freitagabends für die vielen die sich in
den Räumlichkeiten von repair together
Treffen einer ukrainischen
Hilfsorganisation ist gut es ist cool
wie eine kleine Party aber wir machen
was nützliches das den Leuten um uns rum
hilft Paraffinkerzen für die Soldaten an
der Front basteln Sie hier je nach Größe
brennen die Kerzen bis zu 12 Stunden
Wärme für die
Schützengräben warum ist es wichtig die
Soldaten zu
unterstützen das ist unser Land wir sind
unseren Soldaten sehr dankbar für das
was sie tun und das hier ist wirklich
nur eine Kleinigkeit was wir machen
können um Ihnen zu helfen
auch viele Männer sind an diesem Abend
da ob sie keine Angst davor haben
eingezogen zu werden fragen wir sie ich
bin bereit zur Armee zu gehen denn wenn
nicht wir unser Land verteidigen wer
sollte es dann
machen wir haben gar keine andere Wahl
als zu gewinnen sonst sehe ich überhaupt
keine
Perspektive der Blick auf ihr Land hat
sich seit Kriegsbeginn radikal verändert
sagen uns viele Dinge die sie früher nie
in zogen hätten geben plötzlich
halt es ist die freiwillige Arbeit die
hilft mit dieser Realität
zurechtzukommen das ist wie eine Insel
der Gutherzigkeit und der
Wärme helfen um sich selbst zu helfen an
diesem Freitagabend in Kiev ist es das
was
zählt jetzt ein ganz anderes Thema so
sieht BDE aus Europas Kulturhauptstadt
ganz hoch im Norden zur Stunde geht los
mit einer Show im Hafen 40.000 Menschen
leben hier an der Küste Norwegens in
Bude immer dabei die Atem beraubende
Natur und mit mehr als 1000
Veranstaltungen wird BDE in diesem Jahr
ganz sicher ein arktischer kulturhotspot
Clas Thomsen
berichtet irgendwie hat am Ende doch
noch alles geklappt in diesen Minuten
läuft sie die große Eröffnungsfeier in
boudeu der Sturm der die Veranstalter
die letzten Tage auf Trab hielt macht
eine Pause mit dem kleinen Küstenort in
Norwegen ist die Veranstaltung erstmals
nördlich des Polarkreises angesiedelt
mit allen
Widrigkeiten es ist irgendwie typisch
für die Stadt und die Region dass man
das Unmögliche erreichen will es gab
auch viele Widerstände aber am Ende hat
es doch
geklappt wegen des Sturms der Vortage
wurde gezittert ob die
eröffnungsperformance die mit dem
Berliner Künstlerkollektiv Phase 7
umgesetzt wird stattfindet denn die
Bühne schwimmt im Hafen ungeachtet des
unkalkulierbaren Wetters Sturm das ist
ein großes Thema in boude die Natur mit
all ihrer Macht und Schönheit wird eine
große Rolle spielen im Programm der
Kulturhauptstadt doch fast hätte einer
der heftigsten Stürme der vergangenen
Jahrzehnte das gesamte
Eröffnungsprogramm gekippt die Menschen
BDE stolz dass sie nun für ein Jahr ein
Zentrum der europäischen Kultur sein
sollen ich hoffe dass einige Leute in
diesem Jahr hierherkommen und etwas
erleben was sie bisher noch nicht
kennen wird es W nach all den
coronajahren und so endlich machen wir
es eingebunden auch die Sami in dieser
für sie traditionsreichen Region viele
Menschen des Volkes in Lapland legen
großen Wert auf die Erhaltung ihrer
naturverbundenen
Kultur es ist toll unsere ursprüngliche
Lebensweise zeigen zu können wir haben
immer hier gelebt und so können wir
zeigen dass wir noch immer da sind und
dass unsere Kultur lebendig
ist die Natur genießen draußen sein ob
es schneit stmt oder die Sonne scheint
ein gelungener norwegischer Auftakt für
ein Jahr als kulturhauptstatt
Europas so hier geht's jetzt sportlich
weiter Christin neben Wintersport und
Fußball hast du auch Tennis im Angebot
weil es einen schönen Erfolg gab auch
ohne den Erkrankten Alexander SF haben
die deutschen Tennisprofis die
Gruppenphase des Davis Cups erreicht
nach dem Sieg des Doppels gravitz püz
gegen die Gastgeber aus Ungarn sichert
Jan Lennart Struff den entscheidenden
Punkt zum
3:1 Jan len Struff ist anzumerken dass
die gestrige Niederlage vergessen machen
will er braucht zunächst Geduld gegen
den kurzfristig eingesetzten Gegner
Matti walkusch dann das erste Break zum
4:2 eines von zehn assen beschert Struff
den Satzgewinn zum 6:3 gegen einen
Gegner der kurz zuvor noch im Doppel
spielte und in der Welt nicht unter den
Top 200 geführt wird Struff die Nummer
24 der Welt befreit sich gut aus
defensiven Situationen und lässt den
Gegner im zweiten Satz wenig Chancen
zwei breaks eröffnen ihm die Möglichkeit
zum Match gewinnen und die nutzt er zum
6:2 der Zweisatzsieg bringt den
erhofften dritten Punkt damit steht fest
das deutsche Davis Cup Team spielt in
der Hauptrunde im
September 20 Spieltag der Fußball
buundesliga und Bayern Leverkusen bleibt
unbeirrt auf Kurs als Tabellenführer die
Ergebnisse bei schlusslich Darmstadt
gewinnt der Spitzenreiter 2:0 Verfolger
München besiegt ladbach 3:1 Freiburg
unterliegt g 1:3 Mainz Bremen 0:1 Bochum
Augsburg 1:1 das Abendspiel läuft
zwischen Köln und Frankfurt gestern
Heidenheim 0:0 gegen Dortmund morgen
Wolfsburg Hoffenheim und Leipzig
empfängt Union Berlin die Tabellenspitze
unverändert Leverkusen und Bayern trennt
zwei Punkte Stuttgart bleibt mit 10
Punkten Rückstand Dritter Dortmund
verliert etwas den Anschluss hinter
Freiburg rückt Bremen vor Hoffenheim die
untere Hälfte beginnt mit Aufsteiger
Heidenheim augs nun vor Gladbach am Ende
bleiben Mainz und Darmstadt auf den
Abstiegsplätzen und mehr wie gewohnt im
Aktuellen Sportstudio 22:30 Uhr bereits
online in der ZDF Mediathek und 23 Uhr
hier im TV zu Gast Stanley ratifo ein
cooler Amateurfußballer aus Pforzheim
der gerade als Nationalspieler Mosambiks
beim afrikaacup war und
leidenschaftlicher Musiker ist klingt
irgendwie spannend zum Wintersport in
Sigulda Lettland feiert Junior
Weltmeister Adam Amur überraschend mit
Anschieber Benedikt Hertel im Zweier Bob
seinen ersten Weltcupsieg Platz 3 und 4
gingen an die gestandenen Piloten
Francesco Friedrich und Johannes Lochner
Lisa buckwitz gewinnt im monobob
ebenfalls in segulda das weltcupprenn
was gleichzeitig auch den
Europameistertitel bedeutet mit
Startrekord im zweiten Lauf kommt die
29-Jährige schneller auf Tempo als die
gesamte Konkurrenz und verbessert sich
von Rang 3 auf ein Laura Nolte wird Dr
und hol Bronze buckwitz bleibt nach
ihrem vierten Saisonsieg auch weiter im
Gesamtweltcup in Führung präsentiert
sich im bestechender Form di Wochen vor
ihrem WM-Start in
Winterberg ja schöne Einstimmung macht
Lust auf mehr dann vielen Dank Christin
ich kann ih noch sagen morgen wird's
trüb oft mit Regen wo die Sonne scheinen
könnte gleich von Katja horneffer um
22:2 gibt's das heute journal mit
Marietta Slomka das war's von uns danke
fürs Interesse und noch einen
entspannten Abend für
[Musik]
Sie guten Abend zwischen den Tiefs über
Skandinavien und dem Hoch über
derbischen Halbinsel wird es bei uns
windig das sehen Sie hier an diesen
orangen windfeldern und es fällt auch
Regen innerhalb von 48 Stunden können
bis Montag früh zwischen der Lüneburger
Heide und dem Bayerischen Wald besonders
in den Mittelgebirgen so 30 bis 40 l
Regen pro quadratmer zusammenkommen und
auch heute Nacht regnet es vor allen
Dingen hier in der Mitte im Norden
gibt's einen kräftigen Wind aus
westlichen Richtungen und auch diese
Nacht wird mild sein mit
tiefstemperaturen zwischen 10° am
niederrehein und 0° am Alpenrand die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 7° an der Ostsee und in den
östlichen Mittelgebirgen und 13° am
Oberrhein direkt am Alpenrand könnte es
etwas milder werden heute meldete
Garbisch 17,3° Höchsttemperatur denn
auch morgen werden direkt am Alpenrand
so 5 bis 6 Sonnenstunden zusammenkommen
sonst wird das ein trüber Sonntag häufig
mit Regen etwas Sonnenschein gibt's auch
an den Küsten von Nord und Ostsee und
die neue Woche startet sehr mild in
Norddeutschland ziehen immer wieder
Regenwolken durch im Süden ist es
deutlich sonniger schönen Abend